let me pull up this story from
timcast.com Matt Gates votes Trump for
house speaker and not just that he stood
up and nominated him and it was the
greatest thing look Trump's not going to
win but they act C-SPAN actually added
Trump's name to the vote tally and
there's like one vote from Matt Gates
what was funny about this is not just
that is that he's sitting next to
Marjorie Taylor green when he's when
he's announcing this vote and she's
voting for McCarthy but back to what you
were saying Trump having been retired my
first question before we get into what
Trump is up to
would Trump at this point based on what
you said would Trump be if he could be
would he be a good speaker I don't think
Trump has any interest in being the
speaker but hold on I know I know that
my question is would we even want him to
be I would take him but is he a better
candidate than someone like uh Steve
scalise who's like a compromise
candidate I don't know because Trump
gives the establishment everything that
they want he's not the independent when
he said during the swamp he didn't do it
when he said build the wall he didn't do
it so why would we even want him at this
point he's not anti-establishment he's
establishment he's Paul McCarthy he's
promo If he if he did get in how much
you want to bet he'd be like Okay Kevin
what should I do
yeah he has I don't it probably doesn't
even know what the speaker of the house
is supposed to do at this point does he
have any idea what the speaker of the
house does I think I didn't ask him I
didn't Bannon say Trump should be
speaker as well
at this point so look man a few months
ago I was like oh this is maybe Trump
now I'm like the Santa's very heavy
because Trump seems to be just out of
the game like my choice like he's she's
like I'm chilling dude leave me alone
that brings me to an interesting
question in the Republican debates
you're going to see retired Trump not
like strong 2015 Trump but like retired
Trump you saw his uh his speech
announcing his run he looked pretty
tired DeSantis who you could watch his
uh debate one for governor he choked
pretty hard like he didn't do so well in
those debates a little dry he's a little
dry tennis is a dry and you know not so
charismatic and then it's a fact yay is
going to be in those days yay is going
to be in those debates Bring It On do
you think it's really possible
the debates are are controlled by a
bureaucratic force of Democrats and
Republicans that kick out anyone from
the third party they only make sure that
their swamp candidates are pretty much
in there how would I don't know who is
they who says
establishment Democrat and Republicans
that that run the presidential debate
committee which is a private
organization that pretty much is there
to kick anyone else out that isn't a
part of the swamp okay I'm sorry I
interrupted you no you're okay yeah is
one of the most charismatic people in
human history like him or not disagree
with him or not he's one of the most
charismatic people in human history I
know that he's been talking to Ali
Alexander who's maybe the smartest
political strategist uh in the country
so the most charismatic guy with the
smartest political strategist in a
debate with retired Trump uh you know
not so strong DeSantis in a debate and
then the rest of the whatever
establishment candidates they roll out
Pompeo you might see something very
surprising in those debates I don't
think Haley we gotta shout out Shane
Cashman again because he also wrote the
yay article and got to sit down with yay
people need to get this when yay got up
and left Shane Cashman he's a huge fan
of Kanye West as an artist and and knows
a lot about his life and career and
Shane went up to yay and started talking
to him and I here's my opinion on what
happened because I don't want to speak
for Shane or yay but I think yay
immediately recognized that Shane
actually knew what he was talking about
Shane was referencing things about yay's
career that he could see in what was
happening now one of the things he
mentioned was that yay has this Arc of
bombing with negative press and then
rising up really big even bigger and he
and and there's an element of maybe yay
is trying to do nuclear bad press as
part of some kind of strategy or
something but Shane talks to yay yay
immediately goes come with us fly out
and so we you know Shane didn't go but
but a few days later we're like bro like
go talk to these guys and then he
decided he was gonna go do it he got to
actually sit down with yay it's a really
really interesting article you need to
understand yay's strategy because we sit
here and we and we laugh about the
absurdity of his Alex Jones interview
but if this guy
has continually found a way to you know
dive and then re you know and then come
back like a phoenix yeah like I think
I think you'd be a fool to underestimate
a guy who was able to make himself a
billionaire whether it be Trump or yay
they made fun of look I I don't know I
think that Alex Jones interview was nuts
don't get me wrong but everybody made
fun of trump and I think you know one of
the things yea said to me was that Trump
opened the door and showed us how so I
wonder if he's actually doing something
I'm not saying he's going to win but I'm
saying when it comes to the debates I I
lean towards agreeing with you I don't I
don't know that's a tough call but he's
a charismatic powerful guy I think he
could find his way in I think your man
Shane Cashman hit on something because
I'm a Jew when I first watched The Alex
Jones interview with yay and he was um
saying positive things about the Nazis I
really didn't like it I'm not gonna lie
like I did not enjoy it but then I
listened more and he was saying I love
everybody I love the doctor that killed
my mother I love Mao satung he was
trying to preach Christian values which
is that uh he loves everyone that's what
Ian was saying yeah he was saying the
same thing it was brute low weighted it
was Brute Force so it came off you know
with these little clips that taken out
of context make them look like a psycho
but that's what happens when you're
radically honestly hold on to be fair in
context it made him look like a psych
but not if you listen to the whole
interview because what you're saying
Andrew is accurate he started to talk
about all the villains of history and
how he has love for these people even
people that have wronged him personally
I haven't heard the Mouse stuff I I did
hear him just focus on that one leader
in Germany in 1930 to be honest with you
did he say Mao yeah he said Mao too okay
I mean it's a three-hour interview it's
easy not to see the whole this is some
so Shane released a clip where he brings
this up to yay and I think you should
listen to it and judge for yourself but
he says it's interesting how you say you
like a bad person really like someone
one of the worst and that is the only
thing said but when you mention that you
love other people you love the Jews you
love other groups no one wants to hear
that portion of it and so it's almost
like
I I guess the idea is kind of like Yay
was intentionally seeing how you would
react when he presented you with a
positive and a negative and then you
only care about the negative thing he
said not the positive weeds out oh we're
gonna say yeah weeds people out that are
like short-sighted I find but it also
puts you at a disadvantage emotionally
for a while after you do it because it
angers a lot of people but you do see
the fools the comedian Owen Benjamin uh
I did a debate with him a couple of
years ago and we were debating about
Jews and he said that you know Jews are
like a sacred cow you're not allowed to
discuss whether they're good or they're
bad and and I told him I don't want to
be a sacred cow I don't want my people
to be a sacred cow let's discuss the
good and the black and the community
otherwise you're stultifying the
community it's the only way to move
things forward like nobody nobody says
how dare you discuss if there's crime in
the black community because you look at
the statistics okay there's an issue how
do we address it if you look in my
community there's way more
disproportionate of my people involved
in things like the negative corporate
media banking I I'm not trying to sound
anti-semitic I've been accused of that
somehow it's very crazy but it's it's
easy to look at my community and say
there's these problems and if you don't
let people discuss it it makes people
very hateful so I don't want there to be
any sacred cows and I think one of the
things yea was doing is saying okay this
is a sacred cow I'm not allowed to say
that I love the Nazis well I love
everyone I have Christian values I love
everyone and he's slaughtering a
negative sacred cow which is Hitler is
supposed to be so much worse than Mao
Mal killed way more people Mal killed
way more people it was like 50 million
or something like that yeah the
starvation star killed more people and
people are allowed to wear communist uh
logos on their shirts that stuff's evil
too here's my thing about this we you
know I think in the 30 minutes that we
had with yay like we mentioned the Jon
Stewart thing Jon Stewart said exactly
what you did that if there are people
who are seeing a lot of Jewish people in
certain sectors Finance or media
whatever and anytime they try and bring
that up they're they're attacked then
it's it's going to actually make things
worse yep and I agree with that my issue
is
look before we went live yay was calm
and we talked about all of that I said
you know look but what about Elon Musk
Jeff Bezos Bill Gates and he was like
yeah well you know they work for Jewish
people don't they and blah blah and it
was very chill but then when we go live
all of a sudden he was very angry high
energy like saying that I was disrespect
like I'm gonna get a PJ if I'm getting
lectured like Lex Friedman and it was
like all of a sudden this calm
conversation we had had transformed into
something that felt totally fake and
then he gets out of here and a couple
hours later he got a private jet already
waiting for him at the airport which I
just don't see as being particularly
likely I so I I don't feel like it was
an honest interaction to be honest all
I'll say to that is that um one of the
the wisest sadiq's a righteous named
ravaslog said is that all you can really
choose in life is who you surround
yourself with and at the time that he
did the interview with you he had like
Milo in his corner and I don't have very
many nice things to say about Milo okay
I'm not a fan and Milo is not with you
anymore and Ali Alexander is and I have
a lot of good things to say about ali
Alexander I've known him for years and
he's a positive force you can listen to
him
he espouses Christian values and lives
it more than just about anybody and
though I'm a Jew if this country doesn't
return to God this country will fall
look at Europe Europe is they always say
Europe is like 10 years ahead of us or
England's 10 years ahead of us England
is falling into the garbage because
those people are largely atheists and if
America doesn't return to being
Christian because it's not going to be a
Jewish Nation it's not going to be a
Muslim Nation if this doesn't become a
Christian Nation again this country is
not going to stand it's oh I'm sorry to
interrupt man what was it next thing
you're going to say it's just that yea
actually puts out Christian energy like
you listen to Jesus's King that had
spiritual energy his album Jesus king
was incredible it returned people to
Christ into God he needs he needs to
hang out with Shane Cashman
his article is incredible yeah his his
and and really we mean it and I think
Shane understands Kanye's career and
understands the christ-like stuff and I
think would be a positive influence to
get away from that weird stuff that he
did on Alex Jones something I was
learning while from what happened when
he was on the show and the whole Jewish
conversation around Kanye and everything
was uh that a lot of the people that
call themselves Jewish don't believe in
God at that point I'm like I don't I
question that you're even a Jew at that
point like you might be in Israelite
because you are derived from Jacob
Jacob's tribe Jacob is Israel Judah his
son
spawn the Jewish people but they it was
the god that was but but if not for God
they would not exist so like I just
gotta say it's a semantic argument
Jewish religion Israelite by culture
that's what I'm proposing but you're
just you're just making a semantic
argument I don't think so because people
call themselves cultural Jews I get it
you're from the tribe of Judah but
you're really you're also from the tribe
of Israel like you are in Israelite
there are Jews uh in Israel that say
what's happening in America is like a
second Holocaust because there's so many
Jews that are becoming atheists and
because they don't uh care about
anything about the Torah they're willing
to intermarry to the point where their
their descendants are not going to be
Jewish so they say it's like a second
Holocaust because these people
eventually you could say that uh you
could call it now that they're not
Jewish now but if if they're atheist and
they intermarry and eventually their
kids will not be Jewish so that is the
diminishment of the tribe in the way in
which Ian is describing it but I will
say that the problem with the The
Atheist Jews in this country is the same
problem with any other atheist if you
are disconnecting from God you're not
going to have truth in your life at some
point you can do great things in this
world but if you're not connected to God
at some point you're going to fall I
love Scott Adams I think Scott Adams is
one of the most incredible commentators
of our lifetimes how he explained Trump
to people but at a certain point it's
like his commentary went a little Askew
and I believe if he were connected to
God that would never have happened I I
don't mean the bogart them I go ahead no
no I wanted to say it's it's believing
in something bigger than yourself and
whatever that means I see what I see a
lot of people is like I don't care if
you're an atheist I care if you hold
yourself above all others and so we end
up getting there's there's a couple
different ways to look at atheism that
we've seen there have been moderate
secular people who are good people who
are moral people who don't want to
infringe on anybody don't think they're
better than you they just don't believe
in God but now we're seeing a lot of
young people who are atheists and think
that's carte blanche to be narcissists
to be eager tests to be entitled or to
just inherently have those traits within
them because they don't think there's
anything else they're like well there's
no God it's only me then I'm the only
thing that matters everything is totally
I think part of why the Jews were so
successful as a as a as a culture and as
religion and as a faith and as a people
is because they followed the tenets of
God like you don't covet your neighbor's
wife you don't steal people's stuff you
don't murder people you don't worship
false Idols like you don't money all
this crap like the usury thing is where
I start to wonder these people like fell
away from the path and then started
provoking and and using the other people
as slave like usury was punishable by
death for a long time insane amounts of
Interest I I think the family unit is
also something worth talking about since
of course a lot of religious Jewish
people spend their entire Friday night
and Saturday night together that's
awesome that that is that is a
superpower that is helping people
connect with their their loved ones with
with their own you know when with their
own people and and I think that that
truly is one of the more important
tenets especially when it comes to the
larger statistics to strong family units
to to a lot of success I'll tell you a
personal story I don't think I've told
this anywhere but when the Dante's me
bro thing happened my parents were
counseling me hey don't get expelled
from the University don't go like I
could have gone on every TV show in the
world and my parents wanted me to be
low-key don't get expelled from the
University don't go to trial with these
bogus criminal trials and I I wanted to
go on every show I wanted to go on Bill
O'Reilly and confront him for being such
a war Pig I wanted to go on Jon Stewart
and say how dare you call me a douchebag
you're a sellout I wanted to do all
these things but a voice came to me was
like honor your mother and your father
they really did not want me to go high
key with it and if I did I know I would
have become an egotistical monster I
never would have become a more refined
man and so what you were saying about
the the value in uh actually believing
in Torah or like the Jewish tradition
connect to God without that I'd be lost
and I wasn't even someone that was so
heavy believing in God it's just
something that that occurred to me so I
just feel like if you look at world
history Christianity did so much good in
the world it wiped out human sacrifice
and cannibalism off this continent so if
you're not if you have a nation totally
disconnected from God what does that
look like thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time